but yeah there's a whole lot of heat
coming from the obviously the Republican
side talking about this is just I wonder
how many people be at the mon Park City
[Laughter]
[Music]
count all right so this just in a
staffer was caught having booty sex in
the Senate
room America of the White House and are
any of them senators it was um so for
some reason they're hiding the names
everywhere on like actual news articles
but um over on
X um it says it's Aiden May ssky a
legislative just straight up saying the
name for Ben Carden and they um wait so
is is is that person the one riding or
the one doing he he's the one getting
Ben Cardon is the senator yeah but then
the this is the guy who works the
legislative Aid is the one being the
sexy
boy being the butt being the dick rider
does he have only fans it's they don't
know why they did this yet they're
they're an aid to him horny I think got
horny yeah they're really comfortable
though cuz like cuz if you're like
boning in the office place right maybe
you just like pull down your zipper and
just do it real quick they were like
butt naked I heard paans are very
stressed out so they need to unload a
lot they have their clothes folded on
the side no that's like a it looks like
it's one of those like it looks like
it's one of those like jockstrap looking
sexy things that shit's crazy oh yeah
it's like asess chaps you know what that
is what is that yeah look into it
[__] Ryan man what is
that it looks like assless
chaps dude do Bart now do Bart now no no
no no no no no I just kid I already saw
it dude how many do you think they've
done this before and just not gotten
caught probably [__] yeah dude probably
but naked like that so comfortable
there's hella tunnels at like white
house and all these other places and
they why they [__] in the tunnel yeah no
no they would move girls in and out like
[__] Marilyn Monroe like she's famous
for no yeah like when she was [__] uh
Kennedy and they were specifically made
for moving girls in and out to do the
sexy time not for Secret Service not for
other protection [__] none of that so
like ever since this news got out this
like super there's very little actual
info because it's so fresh but on
Twitter AKA X the memes and everything
are going off dude just everything and
what a perfect time too when people are
losing faith this one just says # Senate
room [__] oh my God pretty good yeah
just everybody's bless that one's
bruised bro why would you do that and
this comes right after they you know
like the Scandal where somebody found
cocaine in the white house and they did
they just gave up on searching dude
they're farting too hard then you can
dust off your shoulder this is like
funny dust your nose off but it almost
seems like things have gotten pretty LAX
in that place so wait who is the
politician a republican Democrat like
who is this guy Ben C I don't remember
Imagine The Thrill though the guy or is
it no way that's him oh God that just
made it very good this might be even
harder to look at he's like the
ball well he's the he's not the one in
the room right the aid of eight to him
was the one [__] oh oh so he's not
the one [__] I don't know or maybe
he's the one [__] his aid cuz you
said that guy was like like y blah blah
blah is Aid I mean if you look at the
dick it's like good for you dude you're
very vigorous for your age yeah it's his
aid but it may not be him administering
the aid yeah so no one knows who the
dick is who the dick belongs to oh it
would be way cooler if it was him
administering actually would be pretty
cool yeah but it's just like his Aid and
then like his Aid's boyfriend or
something it's like oh okay well that's
probably what it is youngers yeah I just
want to know how it leaked
man that's what's that's I'm just like
damn that's crazy there's another photo
too of the aid like on one of the
counters just bent over and [__] yeah
what angle is that he's bent over doing
the doing a really interesting position
yeah yeah it's so hard to tell like
which things are trolls but then they
said this is the this is the dude that's
getting it that's how he really looks
really which is still like that's his
White House outfit who is that guy
that's the aid the pants line up so far
do you think when they do like a
background check to like hire people
it's like they see photos like this and
they're like you know it's a liberal
world like we're opening up our our
minds and I actually think that it's
probably common for highlevel
politicians to [__] around like rock
stars and it's just that we have this
image of them to being all proper and
[__] but I think they're worse than
regular people well we have this
different image of them like seen and
stuff an hour ago an hour ago the office
of Ben Carden um just released they said
Aiden ma shovsky is no longer employed
by the US Senate we will have no further
comment on this personal
[Music]
matter it's not personal though cuz they
did it in public but then who's person
who's the stunt dick who's the guy yeah
cuz someone [__] send it to for oh
they also said whoever the dick is good
for them
is there any leaked footage Emoji is
there any leaked footage of like Nancy
Pelosi yeah yeah there's boob footage I
just see if anything's bouncing around
let's see let's see we just we just want
a bunch of deep fakes do you think she's
throwing it down in the Senate I feel
like everyone did I think any top level
person they're just crazy like House of
Cards bro they're all [__] you got to
be crazy to want a job Bill Clinton got
blow he in the oval all the time I bet
you that's a thing like every president
has to get yeah there's there's actually
there is actually
footage what trying to make you watch it
again oh my God wait is that angle from
like a head GoPro cam this one had a
[__] he had a head
strap over I love the I love the looking
over to show the Senate room to be like
this is what yeah what the [__] yeah you
want to know why it how it leaked I
guarantee it's a little a little
boastful brag to your buddy or whatever
like look at what we're doing and then
that gets sent everywhere yeah and he's
going like yeah [__] on Sate Wi-Fi
yeah dude for sure cuz if you don't send
on Wi-Fi I gets all pixelated bro come
on this true I'm trying to find the ID
of the second dude but there's like
nobody wants to say really well I mean
it's probably hard to identify the dick
yeah that's true they should do a
mandatory dick check dick check all over
the Senate everywhere y yep you got to
get them hard too let's be real you got
to get them hard got to get them from
the same angle too so everybody's got to
put the go Pro on you line up isn't
there cameras in those public that's
what I'm saying like how do you expect
to get away with yeah like why would you
even do it there there are cameras
because they knew that during this hour
there's a 90c switch of security guards
when everything blacks out for whatever
re then why' you fold your clothes on
the side it was dry clean they sent it
out there's no evidence cuz I got to
work after well that one was butt ass
naked yeah the other guy wasn't no
they're wearing like the same jock strap
thing they wearing socks probably I'm
for sure they wearing socks yeah that's
what it is it's like the thing that you
wear the hold your socks up because cuz
you got SK CS I feel like if you want to
be a rockar just be a rock star because
if you get caught doing [__] like this
it almost adds to your Fame yeah you
never heard of a uh that that's saying
how like politics is like Fame for ugly
people yes well not fame for ugly people
it was like it was like that's pretty
funny though it's likew yeah Hollywood
for ugly entertainment for ugly people
yeah cuz then they couldn't be actors
and celebrities and then they they still
want the want Power with unlimited
funding the question now is going to be
what's this guy going to do to to tr
like what's his next career going to be
only fans how's he going to top of this
yeah like what's the he's probably going
to do only fans he's probably going to
be a [__] icon yeah he's an American
icon this is literally America he's
going to turn into an idol yeah he's
like modern day Monica Linsky mhm oh
[__] well nah she was goated like
[__] household name that's true I
already forgot this guy's his name is
harder to pronounce yeah that's true he
doesn't have a very catchy name yeah
yeah you need a catch you need a stage
name Lewinsky and that's true unless he
takes down a big politician there's no
infamy with that yeah he took something
down he sure did see do you guys think
Putin sees [__] like this he's like [__]
we're doing it all
wrong or he's like my plan is working
like d their [__] they do crazy [__] and
they get more and more F no yeah these
are these are this Russian KGB plants
right here dude they're [__] you know
moralizing our Congress and
Senate that is pretty crazy though they
yeah so that's that's the Democratic
Senate is that what that is the room oh
or is that the the Senate room it's for
for everything but yeah there's a whole
lot of heat coming from the obviously
the Republican side talking about this
is just I wonder how many people be
[__] at the mon Park City
Council loads dude oh [__] the only
person getting [__] as the American
people am I right hey come on brother
let's go brother let's go brother let's
go